[Music]
you know way before I came out but it
was always kind of part of the zeitgeist
I felt I sort of knew it more from
references from everything from like
t-shirts to episodes of FAMILY GUY to
music videos to just sort of popular
culture I was more aware of Tron as you
know as a part of those things not
really knowing what it was even on its
own but knowing it in the context of
popular culture then when I heard they
were doing a film that was going to be
some sort of reinterpretation or a
sequel it was all very mysterious
I watched it carefully went to meet with
them a year ago and that was it and it
was like once I saw what they were
planning on doing with it I saw the test
footage in that meeting that they showed
of Comic Con last year and today we
showed it 3d and it blew my mind
and at that point I was like is this a
resolution to filmmaking and I have to
be a part of it chef
I mean you know I I had to like stuff my
fist in my mouth to not ask Lebowski
questions the best is just one of the
million movies
so brilliant but it was great to do you
know often you're doing a sequel or a
remake of a film you don't often have
the star of the original also being the
star of the second one so it was kind of
amazing that 30 years later there we
were acting next to him and he's playing
two parts in the film young and old
we're using this technology that you
know has been perfected to a point you
know way beyond Benjamin Button we
really got the same team that won the
Oscar for that that have created an
unbelievable creature and it was great
to be able to be with Jeff and he could
put it into context for us like okay
we're doing this now in the first movie
this is what this actually meant and
fans of the original will get that this
reference is actually about this so it
was kind of an amazing resource to have
in there I found blue screen acting to
be a lot like theater I mean just really
have to use your imagination you know
when you're on a stage that you just
have a black platform and a room covered
in blue you really almost feel like
you're back in a black box theater or
you know just working on your
imagination and working on bringing up
images that that will get you to where
you need to be and what's great is that
for every actor it can be a different
image I mean really you can use whatever
gets you there to the point of you know
how terrified you have to be or how
elated you have to be you can go
anywhere you can blow your own mind now
we were lucky that a majority of the
students who have filmed our practical
sets so we had these
unbelievable Kubrick style sets that I
should be made the director for his
birthday we made him a t-shirt that said
Kubrick rubric because it was like what
this is unbelievable people would walk
on these you're them guess the Flynn's
flare is kind of shown as this crazy
white cave just beautiful stuff so
although it was difficult to work with
green screen I found it to be kind of a
great acting exercise and actually it
could have been way worse but they did
build a lot of beautiful practical sets
so we got lucky on that dress they built
enough so that you knew just how out
there really was and we had amazing toys
like you know the light cycles there's
nothing cool who didn't like tape and
and do- dunebuggy tied light Runner and
had the cool stunt team ever they are
professional loop kickers
and they basically made us look like
such incredible badasses I can't and you
cannot tell when it's me and when it's
her it's seamless but they did want us
to do as much as we could on our own
like I think they're any movie they
obviously like to have your bug on
screen when you're flipping around and I
push myself harder than ever I'm really
glad I did because I've taken on this
new skill when you're playing a warrior
it helps to know how to fight it was
good
I was just blown away by what they were
able to achieve with so much less than
we had I mean they're talking our suits
are pretty intense and people will see
that next year comic-con when we come
back with more but they were running
around in like white spandex on a black
velvet set and like they couldn't sweat
and they caused a brownout in burbank
like big boobs madness for trauma
[Music]